this is looking south on Branch Road
about 10:20 9 a.m. you can see the
funnel touching down on the outskirts of
town
here's a monster still moving northeast
about 10:31 just two minutes lately as
one of our ambulances on its way to pick
up the casualties this is looking west
on 4th Street about 10:40 - there are
people up to that farm
this is one of the emergency vehicles
for following the path of destruction
and trying to keep track of the funnels
direction
very Simmons chemical here we had most
of our casualties my 11 o'clock when
this was taken we had four fire
companies here and our rescue units the
men in white suits are civil defense
rescue teams
that'll be available fire company here
that's the mayor he's making a quick
survey of damage to the city he's trying
to determine whether or not to ask the
governor to declare the area disasters
before help
you see women trying to find out if
their husbands are among the dead
we're lucky to have the facilities of a
snorkel we'll get into the smoldering
embers and make sure the fire was dead
out
this is the explosion area for wind
knocked over a tank and it blew up
adding that much more habit to that
caused by the frontal
some of the casualties needed immediate
care at the oversight
you see rescuer who's trying to get
people out from under that debris
despite the quick response of
firefighters and rescue teams we needed
help and we were lucky that so many
plaque workers kept their heads stayed
and helped with the rescue work
here again women tried to get to the
engine
there are many kills it was a sorrowful
time for those who arrived at the scene
and found that a member of their family
has been a victim of the disaster we
didn't know how many more casualties
would be under the debris
another part of the plant which had
sustained only wind damage we set up a
first-aid station where ambulances and
other vehicles could get to the
casualties get in and get them out to a
hospital if necessary spectators and
relatives trying to get to and find
their loved ones cause the continuing
traffic problem and there was no getting
them out of the way there's dr. Riley he
was everywhere tending to be injured
rather we went the ever-present problem
of spectator my mother's for family
we were making use of any vehicle but
you get our hands on private automobiles
they entered the dead the rescuers a
frantic effort to retrieve life to
preserve it we respond almost by
constant with total maximum effort
there's no holding back in an emergency
like this you give everything you've got
that's the price you pay
my hospital the city's longest at 11:15
this Thursday morning the staff is
attempting to provide a quality standard
of care for all candidates and their
hospital is damaged without city light
for power
they made net worth
Richard Barnes administrator at Memorial
he has to be everywhere at once this
morning is as hospital strings to meet
this emergency what about this power
prophet Thomas to turn us on in a couple
of minutes the generators working but
it's only emergency light
the elevators are still up right
oh hi dick I had a pager you know
anything yet or I mean you can expect we
haven't been able to reach the plan for
getting a lot of casualties from other
parts of town
mr. Barnes should we use the emergency
analyst do I send a discharged patients
on no I want those units kept right here
until we're sure all the casualties are
without trouble people in the lobby the
telephone the hall or telephone a cab
and give them out here as best you can
yes sir right we had five injures right
here in the hospital cut by glass breaks
well with this patient load how many
beds are we going to need let's see we
had had three DOAs and when it's fired
here I'd say at least 25 more anyway got
some pretty bad burn cases from the
chemical plant they must have had a
pretty hard time out there and if the
tanks was damaged and it blew up I was
just going outside what was in the tank
Richard Barnes can't stay to find out
what casualties arriving from all over
the city he has to keep moving to stay
on top of a fast changing situation
where should the ambulances be sent how
many more patients will need care well
the supplies hold out for hours
communication he can only guess we're
still having problems getting through of
the police called there are more
casualties on the way where we stand on
stairs all available interns and
residents are on duty and look for the
off-duty nurses have come in
we did talk to Garden Hospital they've
got all they can handle over there too
this is Thursday let's plan to discuss
his communications problem and these
other difficulties at the staff meeting
on Monday wait
I'm getting through it's the planet
hello hello this is Memorial Hospital
calling me let me talk - hello this is
urgent
yes yes I know that
they hung up all
keep trying well serious enough to walk
evacuation if they don't close off the
valves I recommend we evacuate the whole
east side of town well we should know
something in five minutes this is dr.
James Hickman the city's Public Health
Officer he has expert knowledge of the
medical implications of this disaster he
will have a crucial role in averting
further casualties at the improvised aid
station the casualties continue to
arrive in the explosion site and care
for given transportation to Memorial
Hospital by ambulances private
automobiles and station wagons
Tomlin is a plastic surgeon but this
bullying is very much in general
frankness
he was carefully injured with limited
professional assistance relatives of the
plant workers and others kitchen and
health fortunately dr. Ryan's experience
on the medical societies disaster
committee has prepared him for some of
the difficulties he's meeting my
hospital these patients have got to go
to Memorial now you know the way don't
you give this envelope to the admitting
physician and write this down tell him
we'll be sending Memorial at least eight
more fair turns eight and for serious
promise okay
one morning just after 10:00 workmen
were busy replacing glass in the main
lobby of Memorial Hospital at the same
time the regular Monday meeting of the
hospital standard this office commends
the medical family of the city we are
most pleased with the outstanding
performance by the staff of Memorial
Hospital in meeting this emergency once
again Memorial has rendered valuable
service to this community with regard to
any suggestions you may have for
improvement of emergency health services
dr. Hickman has assured me he will be
happy to discuss this widget with
sincere appreciation Ralph W Lewis made
a and they you seem to think we're
pretty good and I agree of course I know
that we were like that's true that the
tornado had turned off it was born right
through town I mean we were better
now we're devoting this meeting to
disaster readiness to find out what you
think of our performance last week not
just this hospital but the hairy medical
risk father thankfully if things have
been any worse and the fray we'd have
been in deep trouble nowadays you're
going to have to clarify that you know
as well as we all know that every
casualty that came in here received the
best possible attention there's no
question about that the treatment was
excellent whether the patients were
handled in terms of immediate needs is
another matter we could have done better
let me finish we ought to establish
sorting triage from the moment the first
casualty is admittedly we didn't need
sorry we weren't dealing in mass
casualty we we have no way of knowing
where a good 40 minutes we could
estimate how many more casualties were
going to come in we admitted 42 and all
plus five injured here it could have
been 80 200 or even too much
I didn't we know didn't we have
communication with the disaster areas
I'm in the plant history school area I'd
like to answer that as disaster
committee chairman I was at one site or
the other all the time
I couldn't get through to memorial until
after the last casualties have been put
aboard ambulances dr. Ryan was the
police two-way radio made available to
you I found the police very cooperative
the problem was to find a squad car near
our aid area that wasn't it was guarded
something mr. Barnes you know your staff
there's turbos and up to the shock and
confusion of last week to be just a
little scared at what might have
happened if the tornado had turned north
or if it came at night with no light no
power as recently as three months ago I
remember we decided we couldn't afford
any more generating the equipment that's
true today I'm sure we decide
differently and chalk it up to the high
cost of surviving I'm sure there are
great many things that can be done in
this hospital to ensure a better state
of readiness an evidence that we've got
a long way to go in coordinating the
whole medical ethicist but where do we
begin
where do we go from here
preparation survival mankind has paid it
over and over for the sake of life we
pay it willingly
we gather our injured and bind their
wounds we bury our dead weary bill and
next time we think we'll know better how
to cope with disaster so destructive
so viciously unpredictable next time
sometimes because we haven't planned for
disaster the price we pay is far greater
than it has to be
so much bravery deserves preparedness
but in the face of disaster ready enough
we pay the price if we can
and the clinicals of disaster our city's
experience was a minor entry there was
enough to make us realize that special
effort must be devoted to emergency
services next time it might not be so
easy to pick up the pieces looking at
the problems citywide the mayor and
council were just as concerned as we
were at the hospital right after the
tornado we got two new bulldozers to
speed clearance of debris at the same
time a new director for civil defense
came on to do a train full-time
administrator with energetic leadership
the fallout shelter program including
the marking and stocking of supplies we
have started a couple of years back was
finally pushed to completion the city
began to accumulate additional stocks of
emergency food supplies against natural
disasters at first glance the list of
emergency services seemed almost too
elaborate but even for a city the size
of ours everyone was essential and
that's how we three found ourselves
knee-deep in disaster planning with a
mandate from the mayor to get emergency
health services organized I was tapped
along with Tom Ryan who was chairman of
the medical societies disaster committee
Jim Hickman our public health officer
has an expert knowledge of preventive
medicine and he works continuously with
different city departments we soon began
to realize that no one had ever tackled
this problem before we could study
existing plans but but there was no
ready-made formula to meet the specific
needs of our community the disaster
hazards we were subject to the
facilities and resources we could
marshal some work had been done each of
the three hospitals in the area had a
disaster planner but but none of us had
ever considered hearing our plan to the
other two we had a long way to go before
we could call it a community plan so we
started with simple basic questions
so simple no one had ever asked them
before more stretchers interchangeable
between ambulances and what about the
emergency equipment on all vehicles one
point in our favor many other people
were just as concerned as we were about
the problem at first wherever we went
with surveying our vulnerability to
disaster or examining medical facilities
we had good cooperation then as memory
of the tornado began to fade with it
when some of the eagerness people would
talk to us if it wouldn't take too much
time or cost any money in the field of
medicine and health linking with other
physicians and hospital people we've got
a great deal accomplished quickly we
were dealing with colleagues people we
knew in terms of specialized needs we
both understood we soon drew the local
nurses association into active support
work when the assistance of the Medical
Society we soon had a record of every
physician residing in the area and we
set up a running inventory of the
available medical supplies including
biologicals and pharmaceuticals this
included the stocks in drug and surgical
supply houses we found the State Health
Department of the Red Cross were useful
sources of information and assistance
it's very easy to construct and Chester
was you and Larry come up and help us
demonstrate this method fundamentals are
again very easy to perform but there are
students in this medical self-help
course our maintenance kitchen health
office workers the ancillary staff of
the hospital I tell them if you come up
and help us demonstrate this do not be
afraid that the folded blanket will fall
because of the weight of the engine
personally firmly in place all right
good very few and chest shall pick it up
now and transport them to the back of
the room just like you would transport
an injured person there's basic training
they can function as age in time of
disaster that's very good
Jeremy look like you've been hit we even
managed to get a package disaster
hospital located in our area in sweet
smile away in each pdh each hospital is
packaged in some 660 cases such as this
and their pre-positioned in every state
throughout the country a completely 200
bed hospital in about 650 crazy with it
came a training course for physicians
nurses another hospital personnel our
disaster casualty potential sorry Cedars
a normal bed capacity of our in about
six weeks we had started on a number of
different activities we had accumulated
a lot of data and we were beginning to
gain a basic understanding of what we
have to work with medically speaking in
a disaster it was when we began to reach
outside the area of medicine to draw on
other community services that it got
more complicated this is we've got to
line up an emergency food supply for a
hospital population of 600 that includes
patients and staff for approximately
eight days
but this does come under the city's plan
for natural disasters if the mayor's
office has the resources they need food
transportations a communications network
without this kind of support their
emergency health plan wouldn't be worth
the paper it was written on this problem
of communication to take one example
they agree that should be a simple
matter to link the three hospitals in
the area with a disaster site then they
can control the four casualties no
there's no resources more effectively it
seems simple until they talk it over
with the police department
you can see how tied up the board is now
this is just everyday routine you can
imagine how busy the saying it being an
emergency like you're talking about how
would you go about rating one priority
call over another medical goal yes and
there's another problem doc how would
the police officer to see no witch
doctors authorized to make calls all
right let's take an actual emergency
situation now the police are the first
ones usually to decide we learned that
the municipal police department and the
County Sheriff's Office broadcast on
different frequencies but then we were
learning a lot of things we have known
before there is no problem we couldn't
work out it took more time for digging
and it forced us to think in terms of
the obstinate realities of disaster we
reviewed our plans with the mayor's
transportation advisors another of the
civil defense emergency services members
included the biggest trucking companies
in the city the chief for the County
Road department we must have trucks and
drivers immediately post-disaster
to move emergency medical supplies
sanitation equipment personnel and
perhaps even carriages you say here
you'll need six two and a half ton
trucks and drivers you're going to have
to cut that figure in half at least stop
and we've got three hospitals to take
care of we're not asking for any
additional ambulances that's a
rock-bottom thing every truck we can lay
out
is already committed to emergency
service of one kind or another
we need trucks to clear debris evacuate
survivors bring in food supply you see
doctor you could have the only people in
the disaster business we're gonna need
every single person we can get down yes
sir
and be sure that all the main arteries
through the center of town are clear
because we're gonna have emergency units
going through this yes sir it's 11 all
for our test has been underway for 10
minutes emergency units are now moving
along the Main Street store the disaster
area
all other traffic has been stuck up
there just to see if were at one of our
other ambulances there just passed
through the square you should be here
the disaster scene any minute now
that's fine when you check back now and
see whether anymore just after unit time
of 8 yes 0 for Bay it's a full-scale
disaster drill
for the first time the Health Service
plan we developed is being tested
together with the other emergency
services all of that coordination we
worked on so painfully is starting to
pay off
we have our communication system working
with the help of civil defense this
particular unit is courtesy of a local
cab company and we have the police radio
tied in to whatever we need water so I
can agree grantee with thirds we got 15
hit the flying debris some of them
include bashing this compound practice
and turn managers make secure
this man has a sucking of the chest send
him to Memorial Hospital please
this test is as realistic as we can make
realistic to the point where we can
estimate just how effective we'd be in
an actual crisis and so the last letter
bearer can see for himself something of
his part in the whole rescue operation
this time it's a test next time it may
be for real in one way or another cities
across the land have awakened to this
need and the key role that the emergency
health service must assume sometimes
it's a drill that sets off the sirens
sometimes it's a real emergency
they ultimate test of how well if your
community has prepared for disaster it's
nothing new faced with a choice its
survival or extinction man will always
choose to live sometimes the price he
pays is greater sometimes less it has
never been a bargain the lesson we
learned was that it doesn't matter where
you begin the important thing is to
begin it took a tornado to wake us up
but in a way we were lucky it could have
been far worse what is the price of
survival for you for your city your
community how do you choose to meet it
these questions are yours to answer
you